this is the story of an evolutionary
trap a trap laid by people but which led
to the demise of thousands of
butterflies what went wrong and can we
stop it happening again we start in a
meadow in Nevada with the Edith's
Checkerspot butterfly like many
butterflies the Edith's Checkerspot has
favorite plants on which to lay its eggs
in this meadow
the butterflies first choice is called
the blue I'd marry the butterflies lay
their eggs in the spring a fortnight
later they hatch and the ravenous
caterpillars feed for two weeks before
the plant starts to die back and the
caterpillars enter a dormant state next
spring when the blue-eyed marries regrow
the caterpillars wake up gorged
themselves and build a cocoon
[Music]
then they finally emerge as a butterfly
[Music]
this cycle has been going on for
generations until humans brought in
cattle and with the cows came an
invasive plant called ribert plantain
the plantain doesn't die back in the
summer like the blue-eyed Mary
so caterpillars which hatch on the
plantain have longer to eat before
entering their dormant state helping
more of them survive to adulthood what's
more a mother butterfly with a
preference for plantain is likely to
pass that preference on to her
caterpillars the evolutionary trap was
set gradually the whole population of
butterflies became dependent on the
plantain abandoning the blue eyed Mary
entirely the butterflies did well for a
while until in 2005 the cattle ranchers
moved out without the cows grass quickly
grew engulfing the plantain and hiding
it from the butterflies without the
plantain to lay their eggs on the
butterflies were done for they couldn't
adapt fast enough to switch back to the
blue eyed Mary within a year they all
died for 4 years there were no more
Edith's Checkerspot sin the meadow but
that wasn't the end
luckily butterflies from other Meadows
which never abandoned the blue-eyed Mary
moved in and the population is now
recovering this is the first time that
this kind of evolutionary trap has been
recorded and around the world more traps
like it could already be set waiting to
go off
conservationists normally look for
problems when humans arrive but this
trap was sprung and people left it's
important to remember that humans make
changes quickly but evolution needs
longer to react and the researchers hope
that the tail of the Edith's Checkerspot
will act as a warning
you